here are some celebs that married into
serious money back in 2017 model Miranda
Kerr married Evan Spiegel who happens to
be the CEO and co-founder of Snapchat
and according to Forbes his net worth is
about 2.7 billion dollars back in 2019
YouTube Star Gigi gorgeous married model
and designer Nats Getty Nats is the
great grandson of oil tycoon J Paul
Getty and according to Forbes back in
2015 their net worth was about 5.4
billion and finally Brooklyn Beckham who
is the son of beloved football star
David Beckham and girl group icon
Victoria Becker married actor and
heiress Nicola Peltz back in 2022. she's
the daughter of investor Nelson Peltz
and his net worth is listed at 1.5
billion dollars